Transcriptor: Adriana Blasi
Revisor: Penny Martínez
Una de las cosas más dolorosas
que veo en la gente,
es verlos caminar solos en su pasión
y no disfrutar de los increíbles
beneficios de compartir lo que más amas.
Todos tenemos gustos y pasiones.
Te puede gustar la jardinería,
el cine o las hamburguesas.
Pero si eres un apasionado
de las hamburguesas,
lo sabes absolutamente todo de ellas.
La porosidad del pan,
la consistencia de la carne,
escoger si el queso va arriba o abajo.
Qué ingredientes utilizar
y el método para cocinarlas.
Hay miles de variables de una profundidad
inmensa en cualquier tema.
Y estoy seguro de que todos tienen
al menos un par de pasiones,
en las que no dejas de consumir
información nueva
y no paras de hablar del tema.
Si te quedas viendo vídeos en YouTube
hasta las dos de la mañana sobre:
Star Wars, dermatología, videojuegos,
agricultura, criptomonedas o lo que sea,
es muy probable,
que esa sea una de tus pasiones.
Y te vas a arrepentir
si caminas solo en esa pasión.
Hasta me atrevería a decir, que es egoísta
de tu parte no compartir ese fanatismo
y tu análisis profundo
con el resto del mundo.
Internet y la tecnología
hicieron algo muy interesante.
Nos dieron la habilidad de encontrar
a gente como nosotros por todo el mundo.
Nos puso al alcance,
el poder convivir con gente
fuera de nuestra comunidad física.
Gente que comparte nuestras pasiones.
Por más extrañas que sean,
te prometo que al menos a una persona
de los 7 mil millones de este planeta,
le gusta lo mismo que a ti.
Y probablemente sean un par de millones,
no un par de personas.
Yo personalmente, viví mucho tiempo
escondido de una de mis pasiones,
simplemente porque no encontraba
con quién hablar del tema
o me daba vergüenza
expresar esa parte de mí
por miedo a que pensaran
que soy extraño o diferente.
A nadie le importa que haya
una nueva tecnología llamada MFT,
que permite otorgar valor
a productos digitales,
y que esto vaya a cambiar el mundo
en un futuro cercano.
A nadie le importa
que los nuevos portátiles tengan wifi 6.
Es más, la mayoría de la gente no sabe
que hay diferentes versiones de wifi.
Yo pensé que este tipo de cosas
no le interesaban a nadie.
Pero resulta que a través de internet,
encontré una comunidad de gente
igual de rara que yo.
Y me di cuenta de que hay una muchísimos
beneficios al compartir tu pasión
y al exponerte en internet.
No basta con leer un artículo o ver
un vídeo sobre el tema que te apasiona.
Los beneficios los ves cuando participas,
cuando te integras en la comunidad.
Cuando te haces líder del tema.
Y cuando le dedicas tanto tiempo
que te conviertes tú mismo
en aquello que tanto consumías.
Y creas un círculo vicioso de felicidad,
en el que cuanto más participas,
más conoces el tema.
Más tiempo haces lo que te gusta,
más oportunidades se presentan, más gente
conoces y más disfrutas tu pasión.
No hay mejor sentimiento en este planeta,
que hablar con alguien
sobre lo que más te gusta,
y que ellos tengan
el mismo conocimiento del tema,
o hasta se atrevan
a retarte en ciertos aspectos.
Suena increíble. Pero, ¿cómo lo hacemos?
Antes de nada, que no te dé vergüenza.
Y que se te quite el miedo de que
estás solo, o de que nadie te va a ver.
Porque te prometo que no lo estás.
Si a nadie a tu alrededor le apasiona,
por ejemplo, el ajedrez,
empieza buscando un grupo de Facebook
sobre ajedrez en tu ciudad,
y si no hay, créalo.
Empieza comentando en vídeos de YouTube
o dejando tu opinión en Twitter.
Involúcrate en la comunidad.
Puedes empezar un podcast
desde tu teléfono,
y te recomendaría contactar
con profesionales del ajedrez
o cualquiera que sea tu industria,
y estoy seguro de que estarán felices
de que los entrevistes.
Puedes buscarlos a través de
Linkedin, Instagram o Twitter.
Tenemos todas las herramientas
a nuestra disposición.
Puedes organizar torneos,
hacer directos en Twitch
o crear un club en tu escuela.
Haz todo lo posible
por integrarte en la comunidad
y verás como poco a poco
va a ir creciendo.
También va a crecer
tu conocimiento del tema
y vas a poder explorar profundidades
que no habías visto antes.
También va a crecer tu felicidad
y vas a disfrutar más de esa afición.
Y lo mejor de todo es que también
vas a disfrutar del proceso.
Si tu grupo de Facebook
solamente tiene dos participantes,
ya son dos personas
con las que puedes participar y discutir.
Y también puedes hacer
una partida de ajedrez, por ejemplo.
Si te dejaron un comentario en YouTube,
impactaste la vida de alguien
y ese es un sentimiento muy bonito.
Son personas reales con las que estás
interactuando a través de internet,
y tiene el mismo mérito
que si fueran conocidos.
Te aseguro que vas a disfrutar
más de tu afición y de tu pasión
si utilizas toda la tecnología
que tenemos disponible.
Que por cierto, y por casualidad,
es completamente gratis y accesible.
Te aseguro que toda la información
que necesitas está en internet.
Lo único que te está frenando
eres tú mismo.
Sé el pionero de tu pasión, crea algo
diferente y aporta a la comunidad.
Organiza eventos, sé el líder de tu nicho
y verás que al compartir tu pasión
encontrarás más satisfacción y felicidad.
Exponte al mundo,
aporta valor y conocimiento
que solamente tú tienes sobre ese tema.
Y quizás alguna vez, si lo deseas,
con algo de talento, suerte y persistencia
hasta puedes acabar dedicándote
a tiempo completo a eso que tanto amas.
Gracias.